I'm an ill Jane from Jane irrigation
systems limited we are company engaged
in providing agriculture solutions the
question here is what's the you know how
do you tackle the food security how do
you enter full security going forward in
India for the world and when you think
about food security one should also
think about water security because food
is created out of water and when you
look at agriculture agriculture loses
almost eighty four percent of freshwater
resources in India and almost two-thirds
of water resources around the world and
if you can save water in agriculture and
the way agriculture is done by using
efficient irrigation drip irrigation
sprinkler irrigation all those things
then you can get much higher
productivity from the same unity of land
so what really you are trying to do is
you're going to create more crop for a
drop and not only that that while you're
creating more drop you have to also
ensure that it becomes sustainable so
you should use less resources you should
you lesser fertilize the list of water
less of energy so that it becomes more
sustainable and you also maintain the
land quality will remain good because
the future about the growth in about the
food security is not just about
achieving this quantitative growth but
also qualitative growth and when a
farmer uses less impulse and produces
more output not only it will ensure food
security as well as water security which
are very critical and create sustainable
environment but most important if you he
follows this business model what it
creates is also income security for
himself so that
value creation and when you create that
kind of value creation for the small
farmers especially who are one acre one
hectare type of all day then you are
creating a new ecosystem which is based
on concept of that you create more from
less or more and that is a way to ensure
food security for the world